and now they do they do agree and I
think we might be able to pull it but we
let them know the way we felt and they
can't be doing that
we'll work in partnership with the
private sector but where an emergency
exists and it's very important that we
get to the bottom line and quickly we
will do what we have to do and
immediately exercise all available
lawful authorities to get the job done
this afternoon I also signed an
executive order investing and very very
strongly investing the Department of
Health and Human Services and the
Department of Homeland Security
with the full authorities available
under the defense production act to
respond to the outbreak of the terrible
virus the invisible enemy as we say my
order also establishes that Peter
Navarro very trusted person from the
White House and he's been an incredible
he's done an incredible job for me in
terms of negotiation in terms of
understanding where the world is going
economically but my order establishes
that Peter will serve as national
defense production act policy
coordinator for the federal government
that's a very important position more
important probably than it's almost ever
been in our country and so I want to
congratulate Peter and his family it's I
know he's gonna do a fantastic job he's
been doing that job over the last few
weeks Peter is a PhD in economics from
Harvard has a master in public
administration from the Kennedy School
also from Harvard and he's a tremendous
guy and he will do a fantastic job and
I'd like to maybe ask before I continue
Peter to say a few words please thank
you okay and of course you know the
Harvard jokey and fellow Harvard man you
just can't tell them much right anyway
on a serious note they let me just give
you a little idea the defense production
act and why it is so important we are
engaged in the most significant
industrial mobilization since we will
or two we have a wartime president
fighting an invisible enemy and we have
the full force of government coupled
with the full power of private
enterprise bearing down on this problem
for the American people served what we
had to do today with President Trump so
ordered with respect to General Motors I
want to give you a little background on
that we need industrial mobilization to
make adequate ventilators particularly
in the very short run to help the people
in New York Detroit New Orleans Chicago
Denver Seattle all around this country
as this virus bears down and the
ventilators really are the most
important thing for patients who become
most seriously ill they are literally
the lifeline for people and I've
personally been working with FEMA and
I've been working with HHS and in over
ten ventilator companies making sure we
can get what we need as quickly as
possible and virtually every one of
those companies has been cooperative
patriotic moving in Trump time which is
to say as soon as possible sir but we
did have a problem with GM and Ventech
on the one hand we had Ford and GE
moving forward on a similar kind of
project patriotically moving as fast as
possible over the last several days we
ran into roadblocks with GM we cannot
afford to lose a single day particularly
over the next 30 to 60 days so president
Trump invoked the defense production act
is a wave in enhancing and accelerating
this mobilization I salute him for doing
so it's going to make my job so much
easier for the most part we've had
tremendous cooperation from the private
sector today sir was the right day to do
it thank you sir thank you thank you
good luck my administration is
marshalling the full power of the
American government and we will do that
and that's what we've done and we will
continue to do it until our war is won
economic scientific medical military and
homeland security all of this to
vanquish the by
we are working to sign contracts
immediately with the major ventilator
companies in the country including GE
Philips Medtronic Hamilton's ol red med
Hill Rob and via these are all the
companies that do this great companies
the FDA will be reducing and waiving
unnecessary regulations in order to get
this done we're going to be getting rid
of certain let's say barriers to speed
we want them to get it done quickly
they've been doing it for a long time
they've been making ventilators for a
long time hopefully General Motors will
join in the fray under the normal
condition that you would be regular
times 29,000 ventilators are distributed
in the United States each year in the
next 100 days well first of all we've
already delivered thousands of them but
within the next hundred days we will
either make or get in some form over a
hundred thousand additional units and I
guess to put it in other words in the
next 100 days will receive over three
times the number of ventilators made
during a regular year in the United
States and that doesn't include all of
the thousands and thousands that we've
we've given to the various states a lot
of them we delivered thousands as you
know to New York and they didn't know
they got him and then we also had
thousands put in a warehouse and that
was also for New York and they just
found out that they were there so we
have to make sure that when we deliver
things they get distributed earlier
today I spoke to the CEO of Boeing Dave
Calhoun and Boeing will be producing and
donating face shields to help our
medical professionals on the front lines
they're actually pretty intricate in
terms of the plastic and the quality of
the materials are important they've got
to be top-of-the-line and they'll going
to do thousands of these a week they've
already tested the production and
they're ready to begin producing
all of these shields since they're
plastic shields that go over the face or
bowing is also offering us the use of
their what they call the dream lifter
cargo plane
it's a largest plane in the world and
this is sort of a picture of it they
called up just a little while ago and
that can sort of take anything that's
the biggest in the world and they're
letting us use that for the distribution
of product all over the country
especially the heavy product or large
quantities of product and Boeing will
dedicate up to three planes to the
mission of flying medical supplies
anywhere we need it each plane can carry
63,000 pounds of cargo per flight that's
a lot of cargo I also signed an
executive order giving the Department of
Defense and Department of Homeland
Security the authority to activate the
Ready Reserve components of the Armed
Forces this will allow us to mobilize
medical disaster and emergency response
personnel to help wage our battle
against the virus by activating
thousands of experience service members
including retirees we have a lot of
people retirees great great military
people they're coming back in who have
offered to support the nation in this
extraordinary time of need and they come
back in they don't say how much they
don't say what are we getting paid they
just want to come back in it's really an
incredible thing to see it's beautiful
this afternoon I also signed into law
two point two trillion dollars and
urgently needed relief for our nation's
families workers businesses and
Americans of our race color religion and
Creed and the 2.2 trillion goes to six
point two trillion depending on needs so
it's the largest it's a largest bill
ever signed and not just emergency
relief but of any kind we've never
signed a bill of that magnitude and you
know incredibly it was 96 to nothing in
the Senate and it was essentially the
same thing in Congress they did it very
quickly we in the house they did it very
very quickly
so if you look at Congress what they've
been able to do the house was voice vote
I guess they would call it and something
like that rarely takes place and 96 to
nothing in the Senate for the largest
bill in the history of our country
that's pretty good
and I want to thank Republicans I want
to thank Democrats for coming together
for the whole of the nation and this is
a great thing a great victory this is
going to save companies that are
incredible companies but they're gonna
need some help because of what happened
a month ago they were outstanding they
were having the best year they ever had
and then we got hit and so will help
them out it's thousands and millions of
jobs millions of jobs and I just want to
thank everybody for working so hard and
that includes the people standing with
me right here
the legislation extends a vital lifeline
to American families and American
workers with job retention loans for
small businesses and a big focus of the
bill is small businesses they're really
the they're the energy they're whatever
you want to call it in terms of our
nation they push people have no idea how
big a factor peter can tell you the
small businesses are in this country
from an economic standpoint from a job
standpoint we expand the unemployment
benefits for workers very substantially
and direct cash payments will be going
to American citizens substantial this
legislation also provides a massive
increase in funding for hospitals for
the disaster relief fund and critical
supplies including masks respirators and
pharmaceuticals of all types and
speaking of pharmaceuticals as you know
we're working on vaccines we're getting
some good response and we're working on
therapeutics and cures and we have some
very interesting things happening this
afternoon Apple launched a new tool
created in partnership with our task
force the CDC and FEMA any individual
who is concerned that they might have
the virus canal download the free COV ID
- 19 app on their iPhone and answer a
set of simple questions about their
symptoms and risk factors it's getting
to be a very modernized system indeed
they'll soon receive HHS recommendations
on what to do next including whether
they should get tested or not and again
we only want people to get tested if
they if we think they need it in a few
moments secretary divorce secretary
Purdue will discuss new partnerships
with the private sector that are
providing meals to millions of students
while schools are closed they both been
incredible the job they've done
appreciate them very much we're grateful
for the assistance of Niren short hairy
CEO of Panera Bread Company they've been
so incredible to us and to the people of
our country and Denton McClane chairman
of McClane Global Logistics and they've
joined us there on stage with me they're
going to speak throughout this ordeal
I've been awed and inspired by the
American people more than anything else
more than anyone else Americans of every
walk of life have followed the
guidelines shown incredible compassion
and sacrificed greatly on behalf of
their fellow citizens I want every
American to know that their selfless and
heroic actions are saving lives and I
want them to know and I've said it
before that I'm very proud to be their
president very proud of the American
people my administration is actively
planning the next phase in an all-out
war against this horrible virus we're
now testing nearly 100,000 patients per
day more than anybody in the world and
we've now as of even a couple of weeks
ago tested more than any other country
in the world and our capacity continues
to grow widespread surveillance testing
will allow us to monitor the spread of
the virus and we're doing that quite
accurately and Deborah and Tony will be
speaking about that and coordinate with
the states to contain new hotspots as
they arise with a targeted fact-based
and data Brahe base
approach it's all data-driven this
surveillance testing will soon enable us
to publish updated guidelines for state
and local leaders we want every county
and region in the country to have the
on-the-ground evidence that they need to
determine the mitigation measures that
are right for them each location is
different some are very very different
some are day and night some are in great
shape and some aren't in great shape and
we'll be able to have very accurate
information very shortly we already have
a lot of that information
America's bravely battling this pandemic
through cutting-edge science medical
innovation and rational deliberate and
determined vigilance no effort will be
spared in winning this war we're gonna
win the war hopefully we're gonna win
soon and with as few lives as possible
lost you see what's going on all over
the world you see the lives you see
Italy you see Spain you see all of these
countries going through so much going
through such hell and we're all in very
strong communication I can tell you our
professionals are dealing with them
every day many of the countries so many
countries but many of the countries
we're dealing very directly and closely
and we're going to be in very good shape
in terms of certain equipment that's
very hard to get very hard to
manufacture and at the right time we'll
be distributing that equipment
throughout the world to other countries
Boris Johnson was asking for ventilators
today as you know Boris is he's tested
unfortunately he's tested positive and
it's a terrible thing but he's gonna be
great I'm sure he's going to be totally
great but they want ventilators Italy
ones ventilators Spain once ventilators
Germany wants ventilators they're all
calling for ventilators well we're going
to make a lot of ventilators and we'll
take care of our needs but we're also
going to help other countries so I just
want to thank everybody I want to thank
a great American citizens and a lot of
incredible things are happening it's
really happening and it's too bad I was
saying before we had the press
conference when we signed in a signing
ceremony where we
sign the largest bill in our history and
I said think of it 22 days ago we had
the greatest economy in the world
everything was going beautifully the
stock market hit an all-time high again
for the over one hundred and fiftieth
time during my presidency and the world
was looking good and then we got hit by
the invisible enemy and now you have
countries all over the world reeling but
we're winning it and we'll be bigger and
better and stronger than were we were
even before and we will also have
apparatus in place that works we won't
have broken systems we'll have
incredible systems so if this should
happen together hopefully it won't but
if a thing like this should happen again
we'll be able to handle it very much
more easily so with that I'll take a few
questions say please us a little bit
about these negotiations with General
Motors what were they reluctant to do or
was it a debate over cause their problem
well I've got to be a debate over cost
and we don't want to think too much
about cost when we're talking about this
this is not cost I wasn't happy where
General Motors built plants and other
locations over the years not so much
during my term but they built a lot of
plants in other countries I won't name
the countries but you can imagine and so
I didn't go into it with a very
favorable view I was extremely unhappy
with Lordstown Ohio where they left
Lordstown Ohio in the middle of an auto
boom because we had 17 car companies
coming in and then they were leaving one
plant in Ohio
I love Ohio and what happens that became
the story not that all these plants are
moving in but that you had one plant
they were leaving and frankly I think
that would be a good place to build the
ventilators but we'll see we'll see how
that all works out but so I wasn't too
thrilled and then we thought we had a
deal for 40,000 ventilators and all of a
sudden it became six and then price
became a big object but Peter Tavares
going to handle that and Peter will do a
very good job we'll say maybe they'll
change their tune but we didn't want to
play games with them
two questions for you one upon state
quarantines and the other one on this
search for treatment the first one over
the last 24 hours
governor's in multiple states including
Florida Rhode Island have issue porn to
you the orders for travelers came from
other states quarantine orders yeah and
they are intercepting people on highways
at airports they say this is at the
recommendation of your administration is
that true and if so why it doesn't well
I think I'm gonna let Tony speak to that
a little bit later but we're being very
strong on quarantine we're being very
strong on people not leaving especially
certain states and going to other states
where they have less of a problem me
you're hearing constantly about people
leaving New York and going down to
Florida and New York obviously is a
hotspot and that's why we're building
all those hospitals in New York and all
those medical centers in New York so
we'll let Tony answer that but
specifically you have to understand
we're not playing games invoking DPA
this morning you tweeted about it and
I'm told it was coincidentally not long
after that tweet Ventech and GM
announced that they had reached an
agreement to at the Kokomo Indiana plant
which is a clean facility that makes
electronic equipment produce up to
10,000 ventilators a month what the
first ones to be delivered in a couple
of weeks
who why the need after that to invoke DP
it wasn't after it was before and we
just were not getting there with General
Motors we weren't getting there we're
getting there with a lot of other
companies and we have the people that
are doing it for me in the room right
here and we can help we can talk to you
later about it but we have to get these
people on board we're not looking to get
into a big deal on price we're not
looking to be ripped off on price we
don't want prices to be double triple
what they should be so General Motors
we'll see what happens but now they're
talking but they weren't talking the
right way at the beginning and that was
not right to the country just following
that Express last night you told Sean
Hannity you didn't
think that there was a need for 30 or
40,000 venerate errs yet today basically
federalized General Motors to produce
tens of thousands but hey I think
there's a very good chance we won't need
that many and I think frankly there's a
great chance that we're not going to
need that many but you know what there
are a lot of other people that are going
to need them we have countries all over
the world that are friends of ours and
we will help those countries we're in a
position to do things that other
countries can't so we have sort of an
interesting position we can make them
because we're going to be making over a
hundred thousand pretty quickly so we
can make them and if we don't need them
John that's okay because we can help
Italy and we can help
UK Boris Johnson specifically I mean
when I say how you feeling and the first
thing Boris said to me is we need
ventilators all over the world they want
them and we're in a position to make
them in other countries aren't okay
first can follow up on that Governor
Cuomo had said 30 to 40,000 ventilators
is what he need he basted that on the
experts that were advising him what are
you basing your assessment that he
doesn't need that many well if you look
and I think you can ask that question
best over Deborah but I think their
estimates are high I hope they're high
they could be extremely high we're doing
even hospitals based on pretty high
estimates you know I'm doing them anyway
and as I told John if we do not need
them that would be wonderful we can help
a lot of great people all over the world
we can help them live but I think I
think his estimates are going to be very
high we're gonna see don't forget we
sent thousands of ventilators to New
York and they didn't know they got him
then we sent thousands of ventilators to
New York they have a warehouse in New
York warehouse in Edison New Jersey
which is an interesting thing and we
sent him to Edison New Jersey they were
in the warehouse ready to go and New
York never took him so they knew they
were there so we have to get people
lined up we get we've given that and I'm
not blaming New York look this is
something that's of a magnitude that
nobody's ever seen before but I'll tell
you what the federal government's done a
hell of a job so we sent thousands of
ventilators to New York and they didn't
know about it at the time they were
complaining thousands we had 2,000
in 2000 and then 4,000 and they were
going there in large numbers and then
before that we said many thousands we
want to have so many that we do have
more than we need because we can send
them to other great countries that other
countries that have been our friends and
they'll never be able to do it
themselves yeah some of the governors
are not appreciative of what the federal
government's done and you've suggested
that some of these governors are not
doing everything they need to do like
that these governors are at fault can
you be specific what more in this time
well I think we've done a great job for
the state of Washington and I think the
governor is a failed presidential
candidate as you know he leveled out at
zero in the polls he's constantly
tripping and I guess complaining would
be a nice way of saying it we're
building hospitals we've done a great
job for the state of Washington Michigan
all she does is she has no idea what's
going on and all she does is say oh it's
the federal government's fault and we've
taken such great care of Michigan you
know the care we've taken of New Jersey
I think if you ask Governor Murphy of
New Jersey how are we doing I think it's
a great I think he's a Democrat Governor
Cuomo has really said we're really doing
a great job and I saw the news
conference where he was thanking the
people from FEMA the people from Army
Corps of Engineers this went I mean they
built a hospital like in three and a
half days and it's a big hospital in the
Javits Center and they're building
medical facilities in different parts of
New York and Governor Cuomo's been
appreciative but you know a couple
people aren't we have done a hell of a
job the federal government has really
stepped out here's what more
specifically do you want the governor of
Washington all I want them to do very
simple I want them to be appreciative I
don't want them to say things that
aren't true I want them to be
appreciative we've done a great job and
I'm not talking about me I'm talking
about Mike Pence the task force I'm
talking about FEMA the Army Corps Vince
is no country in the world could have
done what the Army Corps of Engineers
has done and is doing now they're going
in and building literal they're going
into hotels and renovating hotels that
should be for governors to do that
should be for States to do we have the
Army Corps of Engineers so teed up and
so stocked up
they're really psyched and they're
incredible and there's no games with
these people they're in there screaming
get it done get it done does not like
sitting around taking it easy these are
workers these are incredible people so I
think the Army Corps of Engineers when
when somebody for political reasons
wants to blame I view that as blaming
these incredible people nobody has ever
seen it I don't know if you've been to
the Javits Center now I've seen it I
would love to go there but with all that
we're doing we will be tomorrow at the
hospital but there's another we have
this incredible hospital boat it was
supposed to be ready in three and a half
weeks because it's under maintenance a
big maintenance contract we were able to
get it done quickly we were able to
stock it up to the you know top and it's
leaving tomorrow at 2 o'clock it's
leaving Virginia it'll be in New York on
Monday weeks ahead of schedule
I think things even the media I think
the media and and governors should
appreciate it and I have to say the
media's been pretty good and the
governors have been really good except
for a couple and with them it's just
political house Trump do it all well I
don't know you know let's play because
we have done we have done a job the
likes of which nobody's seen because you
know what when they're not appreciative
to me they're not appreciative to the
army corps they're not appreciative to
FEMA it's not right these people aren't
they working 24 hours a day Mike Pence I
mean Mike Pence I don't think he sleeps
anymore this these are people that
should be appreciated he calls all the
governors I tell him I mean I'm a
different type of person I say Mike
don't call the governor of Washington
you're wasting your time with him don't
call the woman in Michigan well it
doesn't make any difference what happens
go you don't want to say they they don't
treat you right I don't call he's a
different type of person he'll call
quietly anyway okay but he's done a
great job he should be appreciated for
the job he's done yes ma'am given that
older Americans are advised to stay at
home and avoid travel is an absolute
necessary for you to go to Norfolk
Virginia tomorrow to know you know but I
have spirit for the country I mean we
have sailors we have doctors on that
ship we have everything I mean I'm not
gonna be jumping around in a huddle but
yeah I think it's a great sign the
President of the United States they got
a ship out of maintenance completed all
the work in a fraction of the time you
know supposed to be there for three and
a half additional weeks and they got it
done and it's in great shape and they're
sending it up so the answer it's a good
question it's a fair question I just
feel that as the leader of our country
when they can do work like they've done
and they've been working all day all
night medical supplies everything
loading up that ship I don't think it's
the worst thing in the world is right
down the road practically right Virginia
and I think it's great if I go to
Virginia I guess I can take helicopter
or plane it's very it's like a tiny trip
and I think it's a good thing when I go
over there and I say thank you doesn't
mean I'm gonna be hugging people and it
doesn't mean that I'm gonna be shaking
people's hands and everything but I
think it sends a signal when the
president is able to go there and say
thank you so you know we'll be careful
Peter mr. president on the stockpile of
supplies for a pandemic yesterday for
the podium you blamed your predecessor
saying that when you arrived as
president you said quote we took over an
empty shelf you've been president now
for more than three years why didn't you
and your administration fill that job
yeah I did we did fill it twice we
filled it twice and we've been
distributing that for for literally a
year we've been filling out every bit of
a nice question Peter thank you very
much
we've been filling it out and we've been
filling that stockpile many many times
it's been filled many many times and now
what we're doing is something different
because I think it's better we'd fill it
so it comes from wherever the point of
manufacture or whatever is we fill it
and then we go now it's fitting that we
take it and we just strip it around now
what we're doing is we have an emergency
we're saying go direct go direct go
direct we fill it only where necessary
but now we're trying to go direct so
they drop it off in New York or they
drop it off in Michigan they drop it off
in Virginia wherever it maybe Florida
the farm is getting a lot of a lot of
things
and we're finding it's a much better
system but we filled and we've
stockpiled many many times yeah we ended
up with an empty shelf yes please
you spoke to a Chinese presidency
yesterday what did he tell you in terms
of data that he's going to share and
yeah how they got the number of cases to
go down so I had a great conversation
with the president of China last night
pretty late in the night it was
fascinating to me you know they have a
whole it's a different kind of a world
it's a different form of government to
put it mildly we talked for a long time
we talked for at least an hour I guess
and one of the things I was asking him
is you know when did you notice that
this was happening we talked about the
whole concept how it happened when it
happened what was the most effective use
I mean was it the fact that you know
distance was distance the best thing we
talked about everything and he's gotten
and developed because they're ahead of
us from the standpoint of time it
happened there actually long before it
happened here by the way would have
happened here a lot sooner had we not
kept those people out the Chinese people
coming over to the country had we not
kept him out but we talked about it cuz
he's had additional experience of having
been much earlier and he's he's
developed some incredible theories and
all of that information is coming over
here it's a lot of it's already come the
data we caught data and we're gonna
learn a lot from what the Chinese went
through our relationship with China is
very good we also talked about the trade
agreement but I must tell you this whole
invisible enemy has taken over the world
nobody cares about trade nobody cares
about anything you want to talk about
trade they immediately get back to this
so we really did we talked about trade
you know they're starting to buy very
heavily from the farmers under the
agreement under the trade deal that we
just signed but honestly he me all of us
everybody's talking you turn on
television you read the papers it's all
about this and you know what it probably
should be mostly about this it's hard to
talk about hey how you doing with
from the farmers they have started very
very large buying as you probably have
read but what we really focused on was
this I also said how have you done with
cures and how have you done with respect
to vaccines we discussed that and you
know they're doing like we're doing
they're working on it very hard they
think they have some interesting
interesting things have have been
determined and we'll see what happens
but we talked a lot about vaccine we
talked a lot about possible cures what
how good would that be I mean that's
game changer so we'll see and by the way
we have various things happening right
now having to do with cures and vaccines
and I think we're doing I think we're
doing very well especially and the
vaccine thing I think we're very close
but as as Toni will tell you that's a
long testing process so we'll see what
happens
you just suspend Tara he never asked me
to suspend tariffs no we're taken in
billions of dollars he never did ask me
that on Monday will be the end of the 15
days just love the spread of the virus
do you expect that you will simply renew
the guidelines or do you expect that
there could be some modification to this
so John I'll be sitting down with this
brilliant woman and this brilliant man
and lots of brilliant people that work
with them I think right Debra and Tony
and we'll be sitting down on Monday or
maybe Tuesday depending on which is the
best for everybody and we'll be making
that determination okay we'll be making
it by the way obviously we're not doing
it for New York you see New York is just
coming into this really heated situation
we're building a lot of things in New
York right now that nobody thought would
ever be building a lot of things are
happening in New York so obviously but
we are talking about possibly other
parts of the country which really aren't
affected to any major degree or maybe we
won't do that because maybe at the
advice of a lot of very talented people
that do this for a living they won't
want to do that they won't want to
expose anything they want to do it all
at one time these are the kind of things
we'll be talking about except for people
at home who are wondering how long are
we going
have to live like this what advice would
you give them well it depends we do want
to flatten the curve we want to see that
curves start heading down in the other
direction at a minimum and we really
have to talk about areas of the country
that have not been affected or certainly
have had a very small effect and will
say I certainly want to get it open as
soon as possible I don't want it to be
long but we also wanted to open safe
otherwise what did we do I hope not I
hope it's gonna be sooner I hope it
disappears faster than that I really
think that the people of our country
have done a great job I looked last
night I was watching and I'm looking
down Madison Avenue and 5th Avenue John
there were no people in the street I
mean normally you wouldn't be able to
see the sidewalk there'd be cars all
over it'd be like rush-hour stuff I'm
looking at it and I'm saying I can't
believe it there are no cars there are
no people there wasn't one person on
Fifth Ave and you're walking down the
street I've never seen that before you
know I guess maybe it 1 o'clock in the
morning 4 o'clock in the morning maybe
but I've never seen that before the
people have been incredible they've
really been when you talk about
distancing social distancing I mean you
know it's we don't have a law we're not
gonna put them in jail and yet they're
really I think there's two things number
one they are afraid and number two they
really are wanting to win this thing yes
yes they're worried that there's not
enough money for them to point to a
trillion dollar bill that you just
signed at the end of the sort of aid
period which would be the end of
September where the restrictions on
layoffs come off that they could be seen
significant layoffs and so I was
wondering what your reaction to that was
and what the administration might do so
yeah we have brilliant people who have a
tremendous amount of money and we have
brilliant people that I'm taking from
Wall Street with secretary minuchin
who's done an incredible job a brilliant
guy I'm taking from Wall Street people
that I've known that you all know
the top people in the world they don't
want money they don't want I mean will
they get something yes maybe they'll get
who knows peanuts what they want
compared to what they would normally get
I'm taking the smartest and most
brilliant people in the world in finance
and they're gonna be dealing I'm not
gonna hire I'm not gonna hire somebody
that's never done it that's a political
person or anything else we're getting
the most brilliant financial minds in
the world I know all of them you know
all of them I mean you read about all of
them I guess some you know read about
and they're probably the smartest of
them all but the fact is we're taking
these brilliant people and they'll be
dealing with United and they want to
help look the airline business I'll tell
you right now the airline base has
always been a tough business it's always
been a very tough business tough to make
money with which it's got every every
barrier you could have that business has
but for our country it's very important
we have to take care of our country we
need the airlines to stay it's also big
for jobs so we will be able to handle
United and we'll be able to handle Delta
and we'll be able to handle all of it we
have plenty of money now will we end up
owning large chunks depending on what
these great geniuses decide alone with
the executives of the different
companies you know it's possible and
they'll make a better deal on the loan
but the taxpayer will then end up owning
a big chunk of companies as an example
Boeing Boeing until a year ago was the
greatest company I think in the world by
far that wasn't to me there wasn't
anything close I believe it was 1% of
GDP ok think of it one company 1% of GDP
it was flawless then it had the problems
and then it had on top of it this whole
thing with the virus
so Boeing will probably need a hand and
we're gonna bring Boeing back to health
but we have the smartest people in the
world we have the smartest I don't even
know if you know that I think this could
be the first time you've heard it people
like Larry Fink we're talking to and
that's Blackrock and we have you know
the smartest people and they all want to
do it they all I mean this to them they
love this country they all want to do it
so we're speaking to people like that
and they'll be able to work it out I
guess my question is there's a there's
probably a tension between
bringing companies back to economic
health and protecting people's jobs I'm
wondering if you're going to intervene
and ask Treasury sir no I think there's
a same thing I mean you know bringing
people back to health and protecting
people's jobs to me and I'm ok at this
stuff that's the same thing that's I'm
in a much different position as
president than if I were an investor or
something but I want to bring them back
to health because I want to preserve
their jobs but I also want to preserve
Airlines because that's preserving lots
of other jobs that's preserving the
travel and leisure industry which is
perhaps the largest industry in our
country if you add it all up you add up
all the hotels and all the traveling and
all the planes and everything else
probably by far the largest industry in
our country so saving the airlines is
very important and the airlines were all
doing wealth you know the airlines were
doing record business a month before
this today let's say even 22 days to be
exact right when we first started seeing
some real signs of problems they were at
record levels last year they had a
record year the biggest in the history
of the airlines everybody was doing well
I mean I was presiding over the most
successful economy in the history of the
world and now we're gonna have to
rebuild it and I think we're gonna have
an absolute incredible fourth quarter
you know it may be it's slightly after
that to be honest but it's going to be
in that time period as soon as we get
rid of this I think we're gonna have an
explosion upward it's gonna be
incredible has issued some diffuse
restrictions in the country yet Florida
has the highest percentage of elderly
and
yes sure do you believe governor's
disentis is handling this well I do
because he's a very talented guy he's a
very good governor everyone loves him
he's doing a fantastic job for Florida
he was not happy with the people coming
down from New York you know they're
flying down from New York and he had a
state and has a state would you know
obviously a lot less problems is Florida
has been doing really well and the sense
of testing the testing has shown much
better results they'll talk to you about
that later but no he was very unhappy
with the people coming down from New
York and I understand that know Ron's a
very tough guy he's a great governor and
I have tremendous confidence in him and
you know he had the beach situation he
resolved that he will get it all
resolved yet please certain counties of
high risk medium risk and noise a
practically speaking how you can enforce
that how can you stop people from gonna
have to speak louder sorry how do you
get how are you gonna stop people from
going from high risk areas to low risk
areas we are we have some very very
strong restrictions but you're right I
don't like it so we're seeing how it
works the dad is coming in on Monday and
Tuesday and we're gonna see how it looks
but you know can we go to a tougher
level we can but that causes other
problems we're going to see and we'll be
reporting back very shortly after my
meetings with Tony Deborah and others
that were going to be me and you and our
vice president we're going to be
reporting back to the media okay
president Jensen with EWTN news millions
of school kids across the country our
Hall include email board restless
learning a little bit online but it's
better in the classroom you know that
yeah and there
and my kids they want they're crawling
the walls and climbing the walls and my
wife is about to lose it right so many
of them are watching right now what
would you say to those kids right now
elementary school middle school high
school what would you tell them right
now we're watching for home I would say
that you are a citizen of the greatest
country anywhere in the world and we
were attacked like nothing that's
happened possibly since 1917 many many
years ago we were attacked and we're
winning the battle and we're going to
win the war and it's not going to take
hopefully that much longer but we have
to win the war and I would say that they
have a duty to sit back watch behave
wash their hands stay in the apartment
with mom and dad they look like they're
lucky to have you as a father and just
learn from it but you know they're there
the young people have been tremendous
they some of them are very happy not to
go to school you understand that perhaps
yours perhaps not but they've been we've
had to know we have literally had no
problem but again they should just sit
back and be very proud of our country
because we're doing it for them you know
ultimately we're doing it for them more
than anything else if you think about it
the other thing that's nice and and the
one thing that has come out and I
learned this again it was reaffirmed by
President Xi last night in my
conversation the young people are really
this is an incredible phenomena but they
are attacked successfully attacked to a
much lesser extent by this pandemic by
this disease this whatever they want to
call you've got a germ you can call it a
flu you can call it a virus you need you
can call it many different names I'm not
sure anybody even knows what it is but
the children do very well it's almost
the younger they are the better they do
I guess the immune system is sadly for
some of us their immune system is is
stronger but actually I'm very happy
about that but they have been attacked
for instance the Spanish flu and if you
look at the h1n1 the spine if you take a
look at the the
the swine flu which was as you know not
so long ago that attacked very strongly
young children kids middle-aged people
everyone ages a age is a factor here so
your children should be in good shape
but just tell them to be very proud of
the country okay just to follow it real
quickly when does the risk become an
acceptable one to allow people to go
back to their lives
determination and you're gonna have
something to do with that look we're
gonna be guided also you have some real
strong feelings the media I'll tell you
what the media generally I mean I've
impressed this a lot of the media has
been fair I'm not used to fair treatment
in the media I don't know I don't know
how to handle it but the media has
really been overall I think the media
has been pretty fair some not I mean I
could tell you who but what's the
personal what's the point but the media
has really been fair I mean they view
this as that we're all in a problem
together and we're gonna win we're gonna
win please yes thank you president
rubble
New York is currently the epicenter of
the outbreak in the US with about half
cases yesterday
Kellyanne Conway knee late a lot of the
blame for that on the mayor I'm pointing
out that he told people to go about life
that's normal and he resisted inclusive
schools and businesses I'm wondering if
you agree and also if I could ask you
your thoughts on the stimulus bill
preventing each your businesses do you
think that's fair inside what are your
thoughts well that's not happening I
mean I think they wrote us out and
that's alright but that's not happening
as far as the mayor of New York I'll be
honest I didn't know him well he and I
are obviously opposite persuasions and
we would go at it but we didn't I don't
know if we ever spoke to other than to
maybe say hello a couple of times I did
down at the Memorial World Trade Center
Memorial once a long time ago so I've
spoken to him a lot mayor de Blasio and
we've really had incredibly productive
discussions I've gotten him a lot of
people we've gotten him a medical center
he's asked for at Elmhurst I know
Elmhurst Hospital very well I mean that
was an area of Queens that I grew up in
boy you talk about a an epicenter that's
really the epicenter of the epicenter
that's really something we talked about
it because that was you know very close
to where I grew up and and you know
knowing it being so familiar with it
it's incredible to see where they have
the trucks I don't have to go into great
detail the refrigerated trucks coming up
and I've never seen anything like it
I've spoken with mayor de Blasio a lot
in the last week we've helped him I
think a lot and I've really gotten to
like him I get along with him very well
now he wants us to do certain things and
we've produced I mean today I spoke to
him with the Secretary of Defense Esper
and we had a great conversation and
we're helping him get some of the things
he needs I'd have to go into great
detail but he's very happy about what we
were able to do for him today and he's
like us he's working very hard but I
can't say anything bad about mayor de
Blasio been my relationship with him
over the last couple of weeks has been
excellent and we've done a good job for
him to talk about ventilators and P P
PPE and that kind of thing but what
about hospital capacity and are you
great question
we're increasing capacities right we're
actually adding on through the Army
Corps of Engineers this is a big job and
we're doing it in many states not just
New York and California by the way gavin
newsom has been terrific i have to tell
you the governor of california we're
getting along really well we're working
hard for him as you know the hospital
ship the other hospital ship and they
are incredible that just arrived in Los
Angeles fully stocked but Gavin Newsom
has been really good and so many of the
governors have been good and these are
governors that I've been fighting with
about different things for a long time
the forest fires in his case and the
border and all sorts of things and here
we are getting along very well
so and I appreciate his nice words I
really do I really appreciate it it's
and the people with me appreciate it
you have another question what I was
gonna say on the issue of hospital
capacity and beds and joy able it yeah
pretty good good question yeah well I
mean look we just started this you know
we were just notified and some of the
governor's have asked us to build
hospitals through extensions through
portable hospitals through things and
you know normally this in all fairness
this is done normally through local
government we don't go in to cities and
expand a hospital that's existing but
we're doing it now because we really are
equipped to do it we have incredible
people and we're expanding hospitals
we're building many portable hospitals
not only Javits Center where you have
four plus your four medical centers but
we're doing it in New Jersey governor
Murphy we're doing it in other states
we're doing it in California we're doing
some in the state of Washington despite
the fact that I I'm not appreciative of
the way the governor speaks we're doing
it in a lot of different locations and
we're doing a lot of expansions we're
also taking over buildings and the city
will go in or the state usually will go
in take over a building and we go in and
equip it and make it so that it's now
hospital functioning they called
hospital functioning we're doing a lot
of that again this is normally done by
governor's and then give it to the city
to do you know you bring it in to the
point but we're doing a lot of that and
they're doing a great job mostly done by
the Army Corps of Engineers and FEMA
couple questions on those governor's you
and your team obviously you've had
classified briefings on the pandemic I
assume for a while now where the
governor's included in those briefings
that you would have got in January in
February when I have warned the governor
says you would have had the information
yeah well they say I had classified
briefings a long time ago which wasn't
true but but we've had briefings and as
I know it the governors have also had
many briefings quite pathetic asses to
tell him this thing was coming this was
a oh I think new I think we knew for a
while but if you take a look I was the
first one to say to China and I have
great respect for China I will tell you
that but I was the first one when they
had the problem to say you can't come in
and if you go back that's a long time
ago
question of ventilators I understand you
have a question whether on your knees as
much as they want Governor Cuomo's
saying 21 days we're gonna have do you
write we're gonna have more than we're
manufacturing a lot of them now we're
accumulating a lot we're taking a lot
through the act we're taking a lot we're
actually taking them and we're gonna
have in a very short period of time and
Peters doing it along with some very
talented people some really talented
people it's very impressive actually but
we're actually taking a lot we're gonna
have plenty and if for some reason if
for some reason you're going to need
even more we're gonna be prepared as an
example we now we've given our thousands
and thousands which I think you'll know
we accumulated thousands we give men but
we right now I think in the stockpile we
have over 10,000 the reason we don't
want to distribute that is for exactly
what you're saying if there's a mad rush
in New York or maybe in Louisiana or
maybe someplace else we don't want to
have given out all of those units the
ventilators and then in those sections
we give them to Iowa but they didn't
have a problem in Iowa give them to
Idaho we give them to lots of different
places and now we have to try and get
them back which is never easy to do Mike
y know John what I'm saying is this we
are prepared for things that nobody has
any idea that we'd be prepared and you
know what when I took this over it was
an empty box we didn't have testing we
didn't have anything we had a broken
system there we had a broken system the
stockpiling we had a lot of broken
systems and I'm not just blaming
President Obama you go long before that
but in all fairness to all of the former
presidents none of them ever thought a
thing like this could happen but we
right now 10,000 ventilators in stock
plow we are ready to go with those
ventilators what we don't want is where
we distribute the ventilators like we
did in New York and they didn't need
them or they didn't know what they
didn't use them if we need them in New
York we're gonna have plenty now we're
getting a lot of ventilators in the next
short period of time a lot of
ventilators are coming in the next short
period of time we're manufacturing we
went to all of the companies I read
their names we went to all of those
companies they are going to go I would
say round-the-clock feeder is that right
they're going round the clock we've
distributed thousands and thousands
already normally these would be bought
by States just so you understand
normally these would be bought by
governors they were I don't want to say
unprepared but nobody was prepared for
this what we've done nobody can even
imagine and and by the way I've had
governors tell me including Democrat
governors they said we can't believe
you've been able to do this and you go
to other countries and we're not only
competing against States because we
don't want to compete against States
we've had a couple of cases where states
were by we were buying and we I said
specifically because I heard about it
pull back let the state buy it
immediately the price goes away down and
they end up buying it but once of
competing against many countries because
many countries need the ventilators
that's why I want to build more if
possible John maybe we'll take one more
question the question was are you able
to guarantee to assure these states
these hospitals that everybody who needs
a fence later we'll get a ventilator so
here's what I'll tell you I think we're
in really good shape this is a pandemic
the likes of which nobody's seen before
I think we're in great shape I think
that number one we've distributed
ventilators a big deal we've distributed
vast numbers of ventilators and were
prepared to do vast numbers I think
we're in great shape I hope that's the
case I hope that we're going to have
leftovers so we can help other people
other countries needs well
together nicely look don't be a cutie
pie okay you know everyone who meets
watch nobody's ever done what we've done
nobody's done anything like we've been
able to do and everything I took over
was a mess it was a broken country in so
many ways in so many ways other than
this we had a bad testing system we had
a bad stockpile system we had nothing in
the stockpile system so I wouldn't tell
me what you tell what you know like
being a wise guy go ahead mr. president
you signed a bill today the size of
which could choke an entire herd of
horses and before you even had a chance
to put pen to paper people we're already
talking about the need for phase 4 yeah
do you see a better base for and where
do you think the prime well it may be
something what we're gonna have to help
States because the states have been hurt
very badly and the beautiful thing about
our country is 6.2 trillion because it
is 2.2 plus 4
it's 6.2 trillion dollars and we can
handle that easily because of who we are
what we are it's our it's our money it's
our we are the ones it's our currency we
can handle it and we can handle I
watched Jerome Powell the other day and
he did a good job he said we'll do
whatever we have to do John we have to
do whatever we have to do the priorities
life and safety and then the economy
life and safety seems like the tongue
further sees that we love user but now
it seems like a lot of things I tell
them it's your life then it's your
safety you know if we need more time
they're not gonna have a problem waiting
it out its life it's safety and it's our
country but we have to take care of
people at the same time we want to get
them out they want to get out our
country was built on that but we have to
make sure it's safe and everyone knows
that okay one more question please
thank you both the World Health
Organization as recently as today and
your own health officials have said that
any treatments that we use for kimono
buyers should be scientifically
demonstrated to be effective but at the
same time you've said that foreign as an
example could be used to cure very soon
so is it wh oh and your health officials
on this point are they so
hydroxychloroquine which is supposed to
be the better of the two seems to have
some good backing we're gonna see look
governor cuomo we've given him 10,000
units it's a lot and they're testing it
it's a malaria drug it's also a drug for
arthritis but and it's phenomenal for
those two things as you probably know
especially for malaria but we're gonna
find out soon I hope it works it's there
were signs that it could be doing well
they are testing 10,000 units it's a lot
and I tell you what I want to thank the
FDA because they approved it immediately
based in the fact that it was already
out for a different purpose they
approved it immediately
so look hydroxychloroquine is is a very
powerful drug for certain things and
it's a very successful drug there's
reason to believe that it could be
successful here now the reason I
disagree with you and I think Tony would
disagree with me but the reason I
disagree with you is that we have a
pandemic we have people dying now if
we're going to go into labs and test all
of this for a long time we can test it
on people right now who are in serious
trouble who are dying if it works we've
done a great thing if it doesn't work
you know we tried but this is not
something that's going to kill people so
we can go in and we can test and we can
take our time when I was with the FDA
you know they indicated that well we'll
start working on her right away and it
could take a year I said what do you
mean a year we have to have it tonight
if we don't have it tonight I want to
test it immediately because it's on the
market in a different form so we know
that so from a safety standpoint at
least we know that but you're talking
about giving it to
people who in many cases are dying so we
want to do it the way this is sort of
like right to try we got right to try
approved for forty John for forty four
years or more they couldn't get it
approved we have the best labs the best
doctors they couldn't get it i got it
approved now if somebody's terminally
ill and if we think we have something
that's going to work we can actually use
it they can use it and I'll tell you
what you ought to do when this is over
you got to do a story on that just
because we have had some tremendous
results before you go could I ask you
something that just popped on Wall
Street Journal says headline the Trump
administration plans to suspend the
collection of import tariffs for three
months according to administration
officials to remember it's not even talk
to me about just more fake news yet look
not even talk to me they're talking
about the only one I've heard that from
like as an example China pays twenty
five percent interest on two hundred and
fifty billion dollars worth of product
that they send in that's a lot everybody
keeps saying how are you gonna suspend
the tariffs well the answer's no but
president she'd never even brought it up
less than it wasn't even discussed it's
fake news tell the Wall Street Journal
you know the Wall Street Journal there's
a lot of fake news too it's pretty
amazing so I want to leave leave you by
just saying I want to thank you for
being here I want to thank the American
public and all of the people that have
helped so much and we're going to give
the podium to vice president pence who
has been incredible and if he's tired
and if he's not answering questions like
he should we have a great reason because
yes and slept at about for weeks but I
want to thank him because he has
dedicated I mean he is a dedicated
person long before this but the job he's
done has been fantastic so I want to
thank Mike all the people on the task
force and FEMA and Army Corps everybody
you've been fantastic thank you all very
much
well good evening everyone
and thank you mr. president White House
coronavirus task force met today we
continue at the president's direction to
focus on slowing the spread of the
corona virus through mitigation expanded
testing and ensuring that our health
care workers have the supplies they need
with cases now in all 50 states and more
than 50% of cases in the New York area
it's more important than ever to adhere
to the guidance of state and local
authorities and for every American the
best thing that you can do a young or
old is put into practice the president's
corona virus guidelines for America it
is the way that each of us can do our
part since we last spoke as you all know
the President signed the corona virus
aid relief Economic Security Act this
makes direct payments available to
American families the average family of
four will receive a direct payment of
some thirty four hundred dollars it also
covers payroll for small businesses
across the country for a period of
several months so that even if the
business is closed they can continue to
have a loan which would be completely
forgiven if they keep their whole team
on the payroll there's support for
critical industries for hospitals and
for states as well as of this evening
the president has issued 12 major
disaster declarations most recently for
the states of Maryland and Missouri and
on the subject of vaccines Emory
University in Atlanta today began
enrolling volunteers in a Phase one
clinical trial of another possible
vaccine for the corona virus on the
subject of testing testing is available
in all 50 states and
as a as a great credit to our
partnership with commercial laboratories
across the country this morning it was
reported that more than six hundred and
eighty-five thousand tests have already
been performed and we are particularly
grateful to the American Hospital
Association whose members are now
reporting in to the CDC and FEMA in
real-time giving our experts more
visibility on those that have contracted
the disease around the country the
president mentioned this but it's worth
mentioning again Apple has a new app out
it is a screening tool it'll help
Americans determine whether they should
be tested it has a easy format a
question and answer if you have issues
about whether or not a test is
appropriate for you you can you can use
the new Apple app to accomplish that as
well on the subject of of supplies and
the president spoke about the priority
that we're placing on personal
protective equipment and especially
ventilators and I will not add to that I
can tell you that this weekend we'll be
reporting on aggressive efforts that are
our supplies stabilization task force at
FEMA is taking to import medical
supplies from around the world working
as we speak on an airlift from a number
of countries around the globe to deliver
very important medical protective
equipment to the United States at the
present moment you've heard the numbers
but from the strategic national
stockpile we distributed more than 7
million n95 respirators or masks more
than almost 3 million face shields more
than 8,000 ventilators and donations to
the strategic national supply we've
mentioned Apple donating some nine
million mass that can be used by
healthcare workers but Merck recently
announced plans to donate 500,000 mass
usps 500,000 masks and a little company
called puritan in Maine is actually
the business now of manufacturing swabs
so businesses large and small all across
America are rising to the challenge as
the president noted he will attend the
embarkation of the US Navy ship comfort
tomorrow from Norfolk the US and Navy
ship Mercy arrived in Los Angeles today
we will continue to focus resources and
supplies on those areas around the
country that have seen significant
outbreak but let me send a word to
hospital workers around the country we
continue to hear anecdotally and
occasionally see in media reports people
who have concerns that their hospital
may be running short on personal
protective equipment in the days ahead
we just encourage you to alert your
hospital administrator hospital
administrators please alert your state
health director tonight administrator
Gaynor at FEMA will be speaking to all
of the state emergency directors in
America to talk about the availability
of resources but also encouraging them
to have a plan to perhaps even use their
National Guard to move medical equipment
from store houses to hospitals we'll be
working very closely with state
emergency managers on issues of
logistics but today we're fortunate to
be joined by two members of the cabinet
who have been very busy making sure that
the children of America have the meals
that they need while school has been
suspended in so many places around the
country secretary DeVos and secretary
Purdue are going to share some exciting
news and in progress that we made in in
feeding children who need nutrition
assistance while schools are closed the
truth is many underprivileged kids would
not be getting school meals apart from
the fact that as we stand here today our
administration has approved waivers for
all 50 states to give them flexibilities
to work with local partners to get meals
to children that are in need and also a
nationwide waiver to allow parents to
pick up meals
well what's most exciting today is our
two cabinet secretaries will reflect we
have private sector partners a few of
whom are with us today
who are helping us speed important meals
to children and to families around the
country you'll hear in a few moments
from the chairman of McClain global
logistics and also the CEO of Panera
Bread about the work that they are both
doing - literally deliver millions of
meals to American families it's truly an
inspiring story and I look forward to
hearing it from them and sharing it with
you but it's just one more example as
president Trump said they will get
through this and we'll get through this
together not only a hole of federal
government approach working with all of
our state partners working with health
care authorities at the local level but
also working with businesses that have
been willing to step up and stand at the
point of the need and be there for the
most vulnerable and help us meet the
needs of our children and of our
families and on behalf of the president
a grateful nation we thank you Madam
Secretary thank you so much mr. vice
president and I just want to begin by
thanking President Trump for his
clear-eyed leadership during these
challenging times for our country and
for our world and vice president pence
for your tremendous leadership of the
task force and for truly making a
difference making a difference that's
certainly true for America's students
and teachers as well most of them as
Owen said a moment ago experiencing
unprecedented disruptions in learning
and in their lives I want each of them
to know that President Trump and his
administration are taking decisive
action to keep them safe and healthy so
they can continue learning we must rise
to the challenge of educating all
children from all walks of life who all
of a sudden are in many many different
learning environments and they're
counting on all of us to find solutions
I'm really pleased to be here today for
the announcement of another terrific
solution initiated under the president's
leadership secretary Purdue is going to
share details of this public-private
partnership but before that I'd like to
prefer to provide a few additional
comments and talk about the work that
the Department of
has been doing on behalf of students
parents and teachers during this
national emergency my team and I are in
contact daily with governor's state
school Chiefs college presidents
superintendents and local education
leaders we are quickly responding to
their needs so they can do the next
right thing for their students most
governors have decided to close some are
all schools in their states for a period
of time as a result students may not be
able to take federally mandated
standardized tests this spring and the
president took action to make sure they
didn't have to
we made the process to delay these tests
for a year fast and painless as of today
47 states have requested the delay or
the waiver and 46 have been approved
within a 24 hour period we also released
additional information making clear the
expectation that education will continue
for all students the transition to
distance and online learning needs to
happen quickly and it needs to include
meaningful instruction and supports for
children with disabilities learning
should not stop or be denied because
schools fear federal regulators or fear
doing something different distance
learning is happening states like New
Hampshire and Florida have implemented
phased and tiered approaches to meet the
needs of students in their states other
schools and states are implementing
creative approaches and working through
practical realities to help students
continue learning in remote Colorado
mountain towns without internet
connectivity teachers are putting weekly
learning packets together and they're
holding office hours by phone to help
their students when they're stuck South
Carolina is deploying 3,000 buses with
mobile Wi-Fi hotspots to help kids in
remote areas access learning that way
this national emergency gives all of us
an opportunity to come together to
educate all students out of principle
it's simply not an acceptable option to
educate none of them out of fear so we
stand ready to assist educators and
their students we're compiling all of
the tools we have produced a law
the great resources that states are
offering to help keep learning going
there are already many existing online
learning platforms and many states were
already offering a robust menu of
courses virtually we will be adding that
information to our website on an ongoing
basis and that site is ed gov back
backslash coronavirus we're using every
tool possible to extend flexibility to
states and communities this includes
funding flexibility where we don't have
the latitude we're working with Congress
on solutions one area is providing
direct financial support to students
families and teachers we will propose
Congress provide micro grants to help
students continue to learn these would
be focused toward the most disadvantaged
students in our states or communities
where their school system has simply
shut down I've always believed education
funding should be tied to students not
systems and that necessity has never
been more evident
we'll also support micro grants to
teachers to help them pivot to
supporting all of their students in a
different environment than they've been
used to we know they are dealing with an
unprecedented situation but it's been
truly inspiring to hear story after
story of teachers rising to the occasion
and meeting the unique needs of each of
their students ultimately we know
everyone's grappling with the challenge
of keeping students safe and healthy
while also building capacity for remote
learning it's an important moment to
realize that learning can and does
happen anywhere and everywhere i think
of the texas dad who started a daily
webinar interviewing friends and
acquaintances in wildly different
careers and helping students understand
what it takes to work in that chosen
career for the history teacher in
virginia who connects with his students
through a live stream every morning i
think of the art teacher in tennessee
who's broadcasting her lessons over
social media or of second lady Karen
pence who prepares packages of art
materials and projects for her students
to pick up with their school lunches or
the principal in Alabama who's going
online daily giving morning
announcements leading the Pledge of
Allegiance and a moment of silence and I
think of the many schools that have
distributed laptops and tablets to
students
who don't have them so they can continue
learning over videoconference and the
ones that just don't have that option
currently like the remote Colorado towns
joy Hofmeister the school chief in
Oklahoma may have put this best she told
me school isn't a building its students
teachers and families working together
to advance learning she's right and
that's our shared mission
let me also touch very briefly on how
we're supporting students pursuing
higher education at the beginning of
this outbreak we immediately gave
Institute's institutions of higher
education regulatory flexibility so the
learning could go online and it did in
many cases it was a seamless transition
and learning continues and we're
continuing to cut federal bureaucracy
and let schools rise to meet this
challenge we vastly improved distance
learning policies which are working
quickly to enact for we're working
quickly to enact for traditional higher
education shorter term programs and
apprenticeships also need to grow and
thrive and as the president has so
effectively championed workers need
these options as they look to come back
stronger than ever from these momentary
setbacks the president promised to
defeat this invisible invisible enemy
and keep our economy strong
he took immediate action and provided
Student Loan Relief to tens of millions
of borrowers we set all federally held
student loans to zero percent interest
rates and deferred payments for 60 days
now with the cares Act that he signed
just earlier today mr. president those
actions will extend to six months we
hope these actions and others we've
taken for those who become delinquent on
payments or have had other issues with
their student loan payments will help
alleviate the financial burden and
anxiety students and their families are
feeling during these tough times these
are tough times but we the people are
tougher
so in closing let me offer just a few
words of encouragement to our students
your education z' can and should
continue learning can happen anywhere
and we will help make sure it does we
believe
you to our teachers we will support you
and help you you are doing great work
keep it up and to every parent and
family we know these are challenging
times but it's in the face of great
challenges that Americans have always
risen to the occasion and embraced
greatness and I know we'll do that once
again I think again the president and
the vice president for their leadership
on behalf of America's students and on
behalf of all of us and now I'll turn to
my friends secretary sonny perdue to
share more on how we're working together
to help support student nutrition thank
you very much mr. vice president while
our dedicated educators are out there
trying to continue to fill our kids with
knowledge even when they're not in a
school site USDA is working very hard to
continue to fill their tummies you may
know that many of these children receive
breakfast and lunch if their school
sites and our federal government
participates with our dedicated school
nutritional and lunch professionals
throughout the country and we have
issued waiver after waiver to make this
flexibility is available for things that
make sense when children cannot
congregate in a singular location that's
one of the first waivers we we did we
issued and when Congress gave us the
authority to issue more we are turning
those waivers around in in rapid speed
really less than 24 hours so we're very
fortunate that we've got a great team at
our food nutrition Consumer Services
team working 24/7 to make sure that our
kids continue to be fed it's a great
partnership that's happening out there I
want to mention one other simple but a
very important point about another
matter that your listeners and readers
may may be very interested in that's the
food supply chain USDA obvious is
integrally involved intimately involved
in the food supply chain we've worked
with all those producers even the ones
who provide equipment and materials for
our farmers and cattlemen and producers
out there to make sure they have what
they need they're part of the critical
and essential workforce there to
continue and the good news
those folks are staying on the job those
who have grown it those who are
processing it our inspectors who are
grading it every just the same way they
always had those folks who are
delivering it patching packing it
delivering it shocking stocking those
shelves
and checking out those customers that's
the great news about our food supply
chain and it's a great American story
mr. vice president under your leadership
the president's leadership this is that
whole of America approach federal
government can't do it all but we got
great partners out there in the food
supply chain as well as our food
nutrition services and our partners and
our school nutrition services doing a
great job to continue get these meals to
kids they're two of our private sector
partners are here with us today I'd like
for them to tell their story because
it's a great story didn't McClane with
McClane global here is partnered with
Baylor a collaborative on poverty and
hunger
along with PepsiCo in order to pack a
million meals a week to deliver to rural
kids who might not can get to town to
these drop-off sites where the other
kids are picking up a meals and again
near in McCart much shorter e near and
chaudhary of Panera Bread Co Panera
Bread their company is also
participating in Columbus Ohio with the
children hunger Alliance there to
deliver food meals that meet the
regulations of USDA under flexible
conditions there to get food meals there
and Panera is looking to expand that
that to nationwide as well so there then
why don't you come and tell us your
story thank you very much
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president secretary Perdue in secretary
vos right now there's a lot of focus on
our large cities and the enormous
challenges that they face but imagine
this you live in Iberia Parish Louisiana
or you live in the Nome borough in
Alaska your schools are closed and
normally your children get two meals a
day at school both parents are working
from home but mom and dad just can't get
to work get to town where the where
meals being offered for pickup that's
about to change and change for the
better because of this USDA program
McClane global will source secure
receive organize a simple package label
and then deliver boxes straight to a
child's home and here's another big
difference for the first time we'll be
able to offer shelf-stable meals that
will last two weeks that's a true game
changer for rural families it's
happening because of the president's
order to do whatever it takes to get the
job done everyone knows that tons of
paperwork can be like a lighter fluid
for a great idea and this is a great
idea we feel tested it in 2019 and it
worked you've heard today about the
administration's work on this project
here are some other important partners
in this effort we have Baylor University
they will provide sponsorship in
oversight in addition we're deeply
appreciative to ups in the United States
Postal Service and we are joined by
PepsiCo company to help get this
accomplished because of this
collaboration in our tireless employees
I can report to you the boxes are ready
to show and after all this is all about
the children who must be fed during this
crisis we stand ready to serve Thank You
mr. president and mr. vice president for
caring about the specific needs for the
children who live in rural America thank
you
welcome Niren Chaudhary her CEO Panera
Bread good evening
Thank You mr. president and mr. vice
president for your leadership it's an
honor to be here and I'm deeply grateful
for the opportunity this is an
extraordinary time and I passionately
believe that at such times we must all
come together and do our very very best
to contribute and make a difference at
Panera our mission is simple it is about
ensuring that good food is accessible to
everyone especially those who are the
most vulnerable such as children and
especially at a time like this and we
are absolutely determined to make a
difference in this regard today we are
announcing a partnership with USDA and
children's hunger Alliance to serve
freshly prepared wholesome meals to
children in the entire state of Ohio to
begin with and hopefully after that to
expand that program across many other
states in the country I do believe that
the human experience indeed life is all
about having resilience in the face of
adversity and also having the tenacity
to just keep going to just keep going
and at Panera our associates and our
franchise partners live that spirit
every single day they are resilient and
they are tenacious and on their behalf I
pledge that we are committed to do the
right thing for the country and help
serve those who need it the most at this
very important time they are ready to
serve thank you very much
thank you so much thank you for your
businesses and incredible generosity in
all of them I'll actually allow the two
business leaders to step out if you'd
like we appreciate you so very much on
behalf of the President and a grateful
nation before we go to questions I'm
going to invite dr. Burks and dr. foul
at you to step forward with a few
reflections on what we're seeing in the
data and as you all are aware over the
next several days our team will be
assembling recommendations for the
president to give further guidance to
the American people to states around the
country and they can both share with you
the importance of ongoing efforts of
mitigation by every American the need to
support what state and local leaders
guidance is to every American community
but also as dr. Burks continues to work
carefully with the modeling analyzing
the data she'll reflect on the progress
we've been made in that I'm just to pick
up on some of the questions that you had
earlier so the the issues that we
discussed with the modeling yesterday
was to ensure that the models were
adjusted for the great work that every
citizen is making in doing the
mitigation efforts and to see if that
was reflected in the request
specifically for ventilators and so we
wanted to make sure that with a limited
number of ventilators and the issues
that we saw in Detroit and Dearborn in
in Cook County and now in New Orleans
that we were balancing and projecting
correctly based on both what the models
had predicted and then whether they were
adjusted for the incredible mitigation
work ongoing in New York City
we understand that this week and next
week will not reflect that mitigation
whether it's New Orleans or whether it's
New York and the New York metro area we
know that the hospital emissions that we
are seeing this week and next week will
be infections that occurred before the
mitigation started but we wanted to make
sure going forward that the needs
reflected that that was what was
adjusted in the Ferguson model for
the UK and I know you're following that
very carefully they believe strongly
that the mitigation methods that were
put into place that informed our
mitigation methods we all were working
off of that same model and I want to
make it clear that those models those
flew models have been incredibly helpful
to really predict what would layering of
these different mitigation methods from
social distancing to staying home if
you're sick to staying in that household
that quarantine everybody in the
household if anyone is positive now
there are other countries that took
different approaches and I want to be
clear because we did hear from both
China and South Korea but it's always
important that you adopt and adapt and
adapt it to your community in the
reality of your country we do this
around the world you can't ever just
take an off-the-shelf approach and then
put it into action in your community you
have to understand your communities and
so although both China and South Korea
removed people who were positive from
their households and segregated them
away from their families we did not
think that our Americans would adopt and
adapt to that situation and so that's
why in our guidelines we asked people if
there is a family member to provide a
self isolate in the household and so
that that person is still there in the
household so I just wanted to be clear
that yes we all heard about what China
and South Korea did as much as we could
we adapted them to the American
situation as the UK has done also and we
just wanted to make we really ensured
that all of the requests for the stock
pile reflected the great work that the
American citizens were doing in each of
these areas to ensure health and then
finally no there was a question about
requiring quarantine I want to make sure
that everyone understood and we talked
about New York residents who had gone to
other places it was for them to
voluntarily self isolate and take care
of themselves because we felt like they
could be exposed and we really wanted to
alert them that the rates in New York
City were high
we're increasing and that they were
probably exposed during some of the most
exposure time period before the
mitigation efforts went in so this was
really about a health of our New York
citizens that then chose to go to other
places both to protect themselves and to
protect others so hopefully that's clear
to everyone about those issues we
continue to look at the data every day
we really want to applaud the laboratory
testing that is helping us it will help
us very much when we can get full
surveillance up in many of our
communities and surveillance around
those most vulnerable particularly in
nursing homes and long-term care
facilities so that we can more rapidly
test both the workers and the occupants
in those communities thank you today
just a few hours ago I had the
opportunity to get on a telephone call
with the people who are on the front
lines the people who are actually in the
ICU is are in the hospitals from all of
the areas that are being hardly hit
including New York and I'm not a supply
person I'm a physician to scientist and
I do vaccines and I do drugs but I am a
member of the task force and I do take
very seriously the responsibility that
we have to those individuals to get them
the material that they need we've heard
discussions about this ventilators
personal protective equipment masks and
things like that they are doing an
amazing job up there and I just want to
have a message to them which I told them
over the phone that as a member of the
task force with my colleagues here we're
gonna do everything we can to make sure
that they get everything they need at
the time that they need that because
they are doing an amazing job up there
and I salute them thank you we'll take a
few questions please I asked you I think
there's about eight or nine days ago
about the data from all these tests and
you had suggested that there would soon
be a website where we would see all the
data or are we closer to that when do
you expect that DME data to give us
tonight as far as I can tell that this
has not been public
please check yeah thank you I've learned
in and I as Tony has described we've
learned that when a community is
educated we all do better together and
so it's important to get that
information out when we start talking
about where the virus is what the
percent positives are and really inform
communities so that they can make
decisions so that people can take
protective measures for themselves and
for their families and I find that it's
important yes for us to have the data
butts equally important for the state
and local governments as well as the
communities we are still because we
worked very hard to get it into the
first bill but it was changed to state
and local labs and obviously 90 95
percent of all the tests are being done
in the commercial labs so in this recent
bill that was just approved it is
mandated that all commercial labs need
to report and so you'll have that data
when we get the data comprehensively
from all the commercial labs well it was
passed today so hopefully we'll expect
it tomorrow I guess what is the testing
standard here you're going to need to
test people who are well or only people
who are symptomatic obviously let's say
in an Omaha ten people walk into a
hospital five come in they're all tested
positive five go home they may still be
positive what is your standard in order
to make these recommendations so I'm
glad you asked because the important
thing about testing it only tells you if
you're positive or negative that day you
could become positive the next day and
so testing should be used intentionally
as a surveillance tool or as diagnostic
tool and I think what we're gonna work
on over the weekend is some weave
together both a testing strategy for
surveillance which you have brought up
in that key point while maintaining a
strong testing for diagnosis because our
first obligation is still to ensure that
patients get diagnosed both so that the
personal protective equipment for those
who are negative doesn't have to be
utilized but also to give those patients
the opportunity to have up
we'll care and I think dr. Falchi
mentioned this a few minutes ago the
things we have learned over the last
just three months was a lot of
information about how best to ventilate
patients I think that that has been
shared across communities and across
clinicians around the globe we never
previously had an experience where a lot
of people had to be ventilated prone so
this kind of information that has been
shared has been critical to improve the
survival of the patients that we have in
the United States of America and we
really want to applaud the countries
who've been giving all of us that
information and sharing it across the
clinical network dr. Betty Sunday will
mark one month since the first death
from this new disease I want to ask you
a bit of a philosophical question I've
known you for 25 years you've been
through hiv/aids MERS SARS West Nile
virus Ebola all of that how has this
nation changed since that first death
one month ago well this is uh this is
truly an unprecedented situation that
we're going through as you mentioned
correctly John I have been through
everything from the very beginning of
the very uncertain days with hiv/aids
cumulatively if you look at what's
happened with hiv/aids over the thirty
seven and a half thirty eight years that
we've had it the burden and the
suffering and the death has been
enormous historic but it came over a
period of time there was the fight in
the beginning well we're seeing now in
actual real time is something that's
unprecedented this is something that we
have never seen before at least in our
generation they've seen something maybe
like this back a hundred years ago and
we're really being challenged to not
only learn in real time to be able to
respond in a way that is helpful and
effective but we're also in uncharted
waters and I think that's the thing that
I find different is that the waters are
uncharted so that it isn't as if we have
an example of how to do it you know we
have an extraordinary confrontation on
the
health and the welfare of the globe
particularly you know for us here in the
United States so as somebody who has
been through all of those outbreaks this
truly is unprecedented so from the first
day - now the first death we've been
through something that no one has ever
experienced in our generation let me say
let me say good evening each one of you
I I trust this was helpful we'll
continue to keep you informed over the
course of the weekend the president will
be traveling to Norfolk for the
embarkation of the US Navy ship comfort
our task force will be meeting through
the course of the weekend and we'll be
reviewing the data and preparing
recommendations for the American people
going